one of the most common questions that I
get asked by entrepreneurs or wannabe
entrepreneurs is how do I find my
passion people want to find their
passion and build a business around it
and you may be working at a company that
you hate you may have some dead-end job
you may have a career but you figure out
you know what this isn't for me I want
to launch my own business first of all
congratulations because if you are
asking yourself how do I find my passion
you are already on the right path too
many people start a business just trying
to make money and if that's your only
goal you just jump at whatever the first
thing is to make money you're not going
to make it those businesses fail if you
look at successful businesses successful
entrepreneurs pick any successful famous
entrepreneur you want look at their
story look at why they got started money
was never the number one reason they end
up making a lot of money but it's
because they're extremely fashionable
what they're doing and they turn their
passion into a successful business so
that's the question you're asking you
are on the right path let me share my
story with you I never thought it would
be out helping entrepreneurs when I sold
my first business I was asked to speak
at the YMCA to help inspire other young
entrepreneurs and said sure why not i
love to share my story I almost failed i
was making three hundred dollars a month
i was below the poverty line i'd love to
help out and give back and so we put on
this presentation and i spent a couple
weeks preparing it and promoting it and
they were promoting it and I put all my
best stuff into it you know it's really
excited to deliver this thing and I
remember the day of it comes and we've
done all this work and I'm walking to
the door my heart is beating you know
boom boom boom boom boom boom I'm
getting excited I'm sweating a little
bit and get up the elevator get to my
room as big room ready to go I open the
door and and my heart I swear stops
because only three people showed up to
this event three people it was a free
event I was promoting that they were put
on at the YMCA I'd spent all this time
working on
and and I felt like such a failure I
felt like wow this this is a this is
almost a waste of my time and I got
there and said you know what the show
must go on these people spent their time
to come out and see me so I'm going to
I'm going to do my presentation and it
was amazing and those three people left
with their lives being changed I
realized that I'd really helped those
people that help them on their path and
it felt so good that I realized I had to
find a way to keep doing this I had to
keep going I had to keep helping
entrepreneurs even though every logical
piece of data that I had said this is
stupid man if you can't get people to
show up for a free event how are you
ever going to make money out of this
this isn't a business idea you should go
do something else that makes money but
it felt right it felt like this was
something that I love to do and i had to
find the way i had to find a way to keep
going and it's turned out pretty
successfully when you're first starting
off a lot of times the signals won't be
there for you that the road the logical
market research data won't always be
there for you and so how do you find
your passion I've created Azuga guide to
help you find your passion and what it
is is a worksheet a series of worksheets
that guide you through the process to
help you figure out how do you find out
what you're passionate about how do you
turn that into a business idea how can
you bring more of yourself and combine
your various passions into one amazing
business and how can you make sure that
you're going to stick with this idea
that you're not just going to start
something off and let it die a couple
months later because that wasn't really
your true passion how do you do all that
that's what this worksheet this guide is
here to help you do on top of sharing my
story on top of all the exercises that
you go through I'm also going to give
you bonus advice and famous
entrepreneurs and how they found their
passion people like Martha Stewart
people like Oprah Winfrey Donald Trump
Anthony Robbins how they got started how
they
on their passion and turned it into a
successful company guys this is the most
important exercise that you're going to
do with your business every other
business rule principle strategy will
not help you will not save you unless
you're doing a business that you are
passionate about it's the ultimate
question to start off with so if you're
in that spot right now where you're not
sure your passion is you're not sure
what businesses start you just know that
you need to get out of whatever
situation you're in right now you need
to get our that job either get out of
that career you need to start something
on your own you're in that spot and you
know you want to build something that
you can be proud of then this guide will
be one of the best investments that you
ever make in your life I honestly deeply
profoundly believe that so I hope you
check it out if you have any questions
let me know follow your passion and
continue to believe